[Musique]
bienvenue quartier lajux bien connu pour
des luttes anti esclavagiste et la
distillerie ben ali c'est ici
qu'habitent françois lauriers un
sculpteur autodidacte passionné en nous
à les joindre
bonsoir laurier belle voix joue ben bon
jour alors depuis combien ton café la
sculpture et puis qui m'ont attrapé le
virus terre la patiente à la bombe et sa
femme d'une cinquantaine d'années son
côté sa venue l'idée de 75 et
de toujours des signes et parce que
j'étais jeune et bien vers les français
qu'ils soient définies tg commencé à
chercher à enlever le décès du bois
je vous ai dit d des sculptures à plat
avait dû je dessinais selon ce bois et
puis je faisais la forme
obtenu un coup sûr le tout gbagbo m'a
dit bon moment et elle m'a marché sur
le tibia et même ceux à souillac quoi
hommage à la matinée
quatre matinées collègues
concernant la capture a dit nick
m'attaque découpé et puis 1,6 ou telle
marque à forte 3,2 pour l'homme s'il ya
passé
même si cette impasse est ensuite montée
des coûts pays sera fait d'ici quatre
matinées pradeilles la suite c'est plus
terne ces ciseaux
[Musique]
la presse une carte mais ces mesures ont
fait mais j ai fait
sécher améliorer ça me rappelle
surtout par le dessin droit
[Musique]
l'administration s'est déjà révélé
beaucoup mais boivre la part du bois ou
quand des images des machettes avignon
que mondiale mais ses 1400 - mouais si
c'est toujours un défi ou a lancé quoi
est-ce moi qui les fais ça pour ce à
quoi renvoie et du bateau au large du
brésil
vous voilà déjà dix lignes et parce que
[Musique]
enfin laurier est tombé amoureux de la
structure il ya 46 ans depuis il a plus
d'une cinquantaine d'oeuvres à son actif
qu'il conserve chez lui plus deux
oeuvres monumentales dont le fameux pied
du neg marrons ou pour du carbet
[Musique]